okay today I'm going to talk to you
about protein synthesis proteins are
really important molecules within our
bodies all of the enzymes in our bodies
that catalyze chemical reactions are our
examples of proteins we also find
proteins make up lots of our muscle and
skin and also there within our membranes
and some of certain hormones of protein
based as well synthesis means making all
protein synthesis means is making
proteins and we're going to see how that
works in our bodies so what I'm drawing
right here is a nucleus okay so this is
within a cell this part here is the
nucleus and just outside this part here
we have website we have this cytoplasm
now within our nucleus we have our DNA
so remember the DNA is a double helix
that's the kind of twisted ladder shape
where all of our genetic information is
stored now we also have this other
structure over here called a ribosome
now what a ribosome is is this is the
actual the site of protein synthesis now
let's imagine we needed a new another
enzyme we need to make a new enzyme
let's say some prote of protease enzyme
so let's say we're running low of
protease enzymes in our body we need to
make some more so the genetic
information of how to make this
particular enzyme this particular
protein is within this DNA molecule
within the code of this DNA molecule so
what we need to do is we need to take
this this gene for protease of how to
make protease and we need to take it to
the ribosome over here because this
ribosome is where protein synthesis
actually occurs okay now the problem is
this DNA molecule is very very long and
winding it contains thousands of
different genes protease is just one of
the many
Jeanne's that's going to be in this DNA
code so this DNA is too big to fit
through this nuclear pore so that's just
a hole in the nucleus and get to the
ribosome so we need to do something else
now this is what happens so first of all
the hydrogen bonds between this DNA
strand on the Zipp so the hydrogen bonds
break and this DNA strand comes apart
okay now what I've gotten here is I'm
just going to imagine that these are my
bases here so let's say we'll have a
couple of C's a couple of days we need C
and G now just come up with a random
code here okay now let's say that this
is the gene for how to make proteins
remember a gene is a list of
instructions of how to make a particular
protein now remember we need to get this
information of how to make this prokhor
this protein out through the nuclear
pore and to the ribosome so how do we do
this and this part is really clever
we form a complementary strand of mRNA
okay so whenever we have C it goes with
G whenever we have G remember it pairs
with C so this is why it's called
complementary do oops I've done that see
in the wrong color like that okay now
whenever I have a on this mRNA strand on
this mRNA strand we have something
different instead instead of T we have
you and that u stands for uracil so it's
just a different base on this M R and a
strand apologies for that being the
wrong color it wasn't meant to be that
color so this mRNA strand is different
from DNA because it's much much shorter
it's only made of one strand and it's
just got the information of how to make
protease it isn't all of the other genes
is
that make off by genome the M stands for
messenger because we want to carry this
message from the nucleus to the ribosome
so we can actually make this protein
here this process here is called
transcription transcription okay so once
we've managed to have this mRNA strand
formed it leaves the nucleus via nuclear
pore and goes to a ribosome which is
situated within the cytoplasm now I'm
just going to draw this strand down here
just because I've got some space to do
it here okay but remember this would be
happening at the ribosome now also
please keep in mind that in reality this
would be much much longer than just six
bases I'm just drawing six just for sake
of ease right now okay so in reality it
would be much much much longer than that
okay now what we have here is a sequence
of bases now each 3 bases is referred to
as a base triplet or a codon
now this codon is the code for a
particular amino acid so whenever you've
got these three bases together it means
you'd always get a particular amino acid
so how do I amino acids actually get
attached and joined together now this is
clever this is through something called
T RNA so we'll see how this works in a
minute okay so T R and a T here stands
for transfer because it transfers the
amino acids to the base sequence it also
this is where all of these amino acids
get joined together because amino acids
are the building blocks of proteins so
this is what we start to have like a G a
C now if we have this code on it means
this tRNA brings in because it's got
this these kind of matching bases here
whenever we get this code we will always
get this amino acid let's say for sake
of argument this amino acid is called
serine okay you don't need to know which
bases code for which amino acids
however this base triplet here this
could be the code for a different amino
acid so again we've got a tRNA but this
time it could be for example glycine so
we can see that the code these codons
are the code for these particular amino
acids and at the ribosome this is the
thing that joins these different amino
acids together in sequence now in
reality we have many many more amino
acids than just two we'd have loads and
loads of different amino acids all join
together in sequence by these peptide
bonds so loads and loads of these
different amino acids all joined up in
sequence so we've nearly finished we've
now got a polypeptide which just means
many amino acids all join together poly
meaning Mamet many peptide is to do with
proteins ok so many join together and
the very final thing we need to do is we
know this protease it's an enzyme we
know enzymes have got a very specific
structure that allows a substrate
molecule to fit into their active site
so the very final step once we have this
polypeptide it folds into its really
really specific shape okay so it's 3d
structure
so just to recap well one thing I forgot
to mention as well this process here
that's happening to connect all of these
amino acids together is called
translation so quick recap the whole
part this all starts in the nucleus
where we need to get the genetic
information to a ribosome the DNA
molecule unzips and we form a strand of
mRNA mRNA has uracil instead of thymine
the mRNA leaves the nucleus via nuclear
pore and goes to a ribosome which is the
site of protein synthesis we then have
each base triplet is the code for a
particular amino acid which is brought
to us by T RNA T standing for transfer
these different amino acids form these
peptide bonds to make this thing here
called a polypeptide which then folds
into its complex 3d structure so it can
perform its specific job thank you